imagine you've waited nine months and
the Magical day is finally here your son
is about to be born
the doctors and nurses gather round
don't push yet don't push yet
okay now push push
here he comes oh my goodness is that his
head looks like a kiwi so much blood
everything is so slippery how do these
people manage to hold on to tiny little
babies covered in goo
okay he's out now they put him on a
table to clean him up this is when
they're supposed to let Dad cut the cord
but they don't this time you can't
really tell what's going on because of
the growing crowd of doctors and nurses
surrounding that little table you see a
doctor slap your son on the leg a few
seconds later he slaps him harder then
harder why is he slapping your son so
hard is this guy trying to get his teeth
knocked out
now if you're anything like me the sound
of a baby crying is pretty much the most
annoying sound in the universe but all
of a sudden you realize that there's a
much much worse sound than a baby crying
that's the sound of silence when your
baby should be crying
then you notice one of the nurses using
an Ambu bag to pump breaths into your
baby
is he dead they don't tell you they're
too busy rushing him out of the room and
by that point trust me on this you would
give anything you have you would give
your right arm you would give your life
just to hear your baby cry
but all you get silence
so that's what happened in November of
2007 when our third son Reed was born he
was what they call a floppy baby he had
a heartbeat but apart from that he
wasn't crying or breathing or moving
most of his muscles weren't working
there are lots of different problems
that can cause floppy baby syndrome if a
baby's muscles aren't functioning that
can be due to a problem in the brain a
problem in the nerves or a problem in
the muscles themselves so doctors start
running tests to figure out what's wrong
it took a couple of months to get a
diagnosis a lab eventually discovered
that Reed had x-linked myotubular
myopathy MTN for short which is a rare
genetic muscle disease MTM usually only
affects boys because it's x-linked it's
a problem with the X chromosome girls
have two X chromosomes so even if they
get a bad one the good one compensates
boys have One X chromosome so they
inherit either the good one or the bad
one which means that if the mother is a
carrier and his son's born to her will
have a 50 50 chance of getting the
disease boys who get the disease will
have extremely weak muscles
in recent years medical researchers
managed to cure the disease in mice and
then in dogs so all of the families of
kids with MTM were looking forward to a
cure the Cure seemed like it was right
around the corner but when doctors began
human trials there were side effects
namely liver failure kids whose muscles
were being repaired started dying of
liver failure
so researchers had to go back to the
drawing board and a cure is going to
take longer than we hoped
this past April my wife Marie was taking
Reed to watch a play he was happy and
laughing
then an alarm on his monitor went off
his oxygen level started dropping Marie
and the nurse went into emergency mode
we've been there plenty of times before
Reed's heart rate shot up then his heart
stopped Marie and soon paramedics tried
to revive him but he didn't make it
the next day I posted this on Twitter
in 2007 our third son was born but he
wasn't moving or breathing
once the doctors figured out what
disease he had they told us he had a 50
chance of reaching his first birthday
and a 30 chance of reaching his second
birthday
yesterday around four o'clock P.M Reed
went to be with Jesus and on the picture
I put readwood
2007-2023 and on to Eternity
the comments from Christians Muslims
atheists Hindus and so on were
overwhelmingly kind even people who
ordinarily hate me said they didn't have
any ill will toward my son
but this is the internet we're talking
about so you know it's not going to be
all prayers and condolences you know
there are going to be some adherence of
a particular religious persuasion who
are going to seize this opportunity to
say something unpleasant
you know who I'm talking about
atheists
to be fair I did get some unfriendly
messages from keyboard jihadis who said
things like
your censored son right now I'm not up
to date on what words are Politically
Incorrect but I think I'm not supposed
to say the r word so that's supposedly
my son Reed in hell
your son Reed is now dirt LOL you will
never touch his hands again you will
never look at his face smiling to you
read is worm food now LOL good riddance
on your son it was a good day when your
censored son died hopefully the next one
will follow censored this guy
photoshopped a pig's face over my son's
face what's with the French Kiss creep
kissing on lips pedo wood alhamdulillah
he is gone for better life than staying
with a pedo dad
notice there's no real content in these
comments it's just keyboard jihadis
trying to figure out how to hurt my
feelings
good luck with that one you know what's
weird
there's something kind of adorable about
these guys spending the past 15 years
searching for some secret formula to
make me sad it's like toddlers trying to
solve a Rubik's Cube they actually
remind me of when I was a little kid
there was a railroad track behind our
trailer park and a coal train went by
every day
I spent years trying to derail that
train I pried up hundreds of railroad
spikes that held the tracks in place I
covered the tracks with rocks and
whatever else I could find
nothing ever affected the train
I'd be there for hours piling stuff on
the tracks and the train would just plow
right through it
you keyboard jihadis are like kids
trying to derail a cold train and I'm
Nicole train
choo choo buckaroos but by all means
keep trying people keep searching for
Blackbeard's treasure why shouldn't you
keep searching for T Woods feelings
and just think if you succeed
you'll be rich because if you can come
up with a way to get tears from these
ice marbles you'll have no problem
striking oil in a bowl of oatmeal or
gathering a jar of honey from a slab of
granite or collecting a barrel of
moonshine from the Moon
keep shining Superstars
caddy comments from atheists are
different because there's usually some
sort of moral condemnation involved it's
not just haha your son died it's David
you're evil because XYZ for instance in
response to my tweet about my son's
death one atheist replied
disgusting only a Christian could use
the death of a child to promote their
religion I wouldn't have said anything
if you hadn't but seriously gone to be
with Jesus I could never bring myself to
worship he who can't even give my child
a working body
so Christians need to keep our mouths
shut about our beliefs when a child dies
if we don't keep our mouths shut then
our behavior is disgusting
there's also a version of What's called
the problem of evil or the argument from
Evil here how can you worship a God who
let your kid have a muscle disease
quite refreshing unlike the keyboard
jihadis This Guy's actually presenting
meaningful criticisms so that he can
help make the world a better place a
place where people with religious
beliefs do not mention those beliefs
when their children die
this is of course only one random
atheist so why even draw attention to
hey wait a minute
19 likes
seriously atheists
then we have
normies genuinely believe forcing a body
to live past the neonatal period when it
wasn't meant to is empathetic utterly
sociopathic Behavior
I think this is the first time in my
life I've ever been called a normie not
the first time I've been accused of
sociopathic Behavior I don't think this
is even coherent Normie is a normal
person sociopathic Behavior pretty much
by definition is not normal
in a follow-up comment about Reed we
have
with his mental and physical capacity
being a little more than a chair I
wouldn't exactly say he enjoyed anything
the idea here is that if someone doesn't
enjoy life his life isn't worth living
so he's better off dead
now I don't know what chairs are like
where this person lives but I've never
seen a chair
do the Reedy dance
I'm starting to think that in spite of
having a debilitating muscle disease
Reed enjoyed life more than a lot of
people who spend their time complaining
on Twitter
but what do you think about the idea
that if someone is born with a serious
disability you should let him die
you could make an argument for that
position you could say well ordinarily
in the animal kingdom an offspring with
some sort of significant mental or
physical defect is going to die very
quickly but because human beings are
smarter and more advanced we can take a
baby that wouldn't survive 15 minutes
and extend his life by 15 years
just because we can extend life however
doesn't mean that we should parents have
an instinct to protect their children
and that instinct doesn't automatically
turn off if a child has a disability
but that's where reason comes in we can
use our reason to say even though I feel
like I should protect my disabled child
maybe it's better to just let him go why
put a child through a difficult life why
use society's already limited resources
to extend the life of someone who
doesn't seem fit to survive
something like that right
of course once you decide that a baby
with significant special needs shouldn't
live the next question is
since you've chosen to go down mass
murder Road or mercy killing Road
depending on your view how far are you
willing to go
one of Reed's Four Brothers has the same
muscle disease he's 13 years old it's a
lot of work taking care of him
should we pull the plug on his breathing
machine
Let's ignore the normies for a moment
suppose we decide to make tough choices
for the greater good and we put together
a list of people who aren't fit to
survive or who are a drain on resources
what sort of people will be on our death
list
people with physical disabilities
mental disabilities
people with various diseases
what about old people they're not
contributing much once they've retired
we could turn them into food like in
silent green
that was a spoiler but the movie's like
50 years old so stop whining or I'll add
whiners to our deathless
what about stupid people should they be
removed from the gene pool we don't want
to end up with an idiocracy do we
what if someone is just chronically
unhappy always miserable and depressed
criminals poor people everyone we
disagree with
there is no mix-up Eugenics can't fix up
am I right
this may sound ridiculous to you
especially if you're a normie but the
world may already be heading in that
direction and it's not exactly a new
idea
there's a short passage in the white
rose that's relevant here the white rose
is a book about a resistance movement in
Nazi Germany
five students and a professor
distributed a series of leaflets
encouraging Germans to oppose the
genocidal regime
the students and the professor were
caught and executed Inga Shoal who was
the sister of two of the students Hans
and Sophie eventually wrote a book about
the movement and the events that led to
their resistance I had to read divisa
Rosa in German back in college here's
the relevant Passage
now and again nurses from schwabish Hall
former friends of her mothers Sophie
Scholl's mother came to visit
in that City there was a large hospital
for mentally ill children
one day one of the nurses called she was
despondent and distraught and we did not
know how to help her finally she told us
the reason for her grief
for some time passed her Wards had been
carted off by the black vans of the SS
and sent to their death in gas Chambers
after the first contingents failed to
return from their secret Journey a
strange disturbance agitated the
children in the institution
where are the trucks going auntie
they are going to heaven replied the
nurses in their helplessness and
confusion from that time on the children
mounted the strange trucks singing
a physician in one of the Mental
Hospitals protested Over My Dead Body
it is not known what became of him
a soldier came home from Russia on
furlough he was the father of one of
these children he had never ceased
hoping that his child would be cured he
felt toward his son the love that only a
father can feel but when he arrived the
child was already dead
so the soldier was out fighting for the
Nazi regime he came home and went to see
his son but the party he was fighting
for had already sent his son to a gas
chamber without even bothering to notify
him
by the way it's a little ambiguous here
but the black trucks didn't take
children to gas Chambers the black
trucks were Mobile Gas Chambers they
were called gaswagen the Nazis would
load kids into the trucks drive the kids
to a mass grave and gas them along the
way
so the kids would already be dead by the
time they got to the mass grave where
their bodies would be dumped
one problem the Nazis struggled to solve
was sound proofing the trucks the
children would start screaming once they
realized they were dying and some
drivers would be bothered by the sounds
of mentally ill kids being executed a
few feet behind them the nurses couldn't
do anything to stop this so they would
tell the children that the trucks were
taking them to heaven and the children
would climb into the trucks singing
songs until they realized they were
dying
I can only imagine one of our
enlightened Twitter atheists scolding
the nurses for bringing religion into
the discussion
so the idea that Society should get rid
of special needs children is nothing new
and people complaining about my wife and
me taking care of special needs children
is nothing new I've been getting these
messages for years the best ones
typically use the machine gun approach
they'll fire a bunch of different points
at me all at once
here's an example of the machine gun
approach this is before Reed died Jordan
says hi David I started listening to a
your why I'm a Christian video I'll put
a link to that video in the description
box in case you want to understand what
he's talking about and became convinced
after about eight minutes that you are
censored again I don't think I'm
supposed to say the r word and insane I
also could not believe that your wife
rolled the censored Dice and basically
purposely brought a am I allowed to say
this G word I only knew the word from
Pulp Fiction and from some perverted
messages that Muhammad hijab sent to the
apostate prophet in me and in both cases
it had something to do with bondage so I
didn't know what Jordan was talking
about here but I looked it up and it's
also a derogatory term for a person with
a disability anyhow I'll play it safe
I also could not believe that your wife
rolled the censored Dice and basically
purposely brought a censored into the
world who will be cruelly and inhumanly
condemned to a miserable existence
because apparently she is as censored
and insane as you are I mean how evil do
you two censored have to be to do that
it blows my censored mind which got me
thinking it's probably a good thing that
your brother fried his censored brains
at this point the whole family is
suspect anyway have a happy New Year you
autistic piece of censored
speaking of death lists according to
Jordan my whole family should apparently
be loaded into a gas wagon and taken to
a mess grave
I'm sure there are plenty of keyboard
jihadis who would agree with him and
speaking of my whole family it's kind of
weird that these guys always seem to
know an awful lot about my wife my kids
my brothers
they know everything about me
I wonder if some of these super fans
have Little D wood shrines on their
dressers
Jordan mentions my brother Manny who
suffered some brain damage because of an
overdose a few years ago Manny had
massive organ failure and went into a
coma while he was in a coma our mom died
of an overdose not sure why Jordan left
my mom's death out of his email
rookie mistake Jordan
unless this suggests some underlying
mother issues put that one in the vault
and save it for later doctors didn't
expect my brother Manny to survive but
he did he came out of his coma he had to
relearn how to walk and how to talk he
stayed clean for three and a half years
then recently he injured his foot and he
went to a doctor who unbeknownst to us
prescribed Manny opioid painkillers
Manny got hooked again and I'm sure
Jordan will be happy to hear that my
brother Manny died of an overdose three
weeks ago so Jordan you can scratch
Manny off your list
Jordan says that my wife rolled the dice
and basically purposely brought a
special needs child into the world
no idea what he means by purposely we
didn't intend for Reed to have MTM I
think Jordan might be referring to our
fourth son Paley who also has MTM but we
didn't intend that either
after we found out that Reed's disease
was genetic we tried not to get pregnant
again but it turns out that nearly all
forms of birth control are completely
useless when the Fortress is being
stormed by what can only be described as
the Delta Force piranha of tadpoles I
can't miss even when I try so Marie got
pregnant again ultrasound showed that it
was another boy which meant there was a
50 50 chance that he would have MTM
that's probably why Jordan said we were
rolling the dice apparently Jordan
thinks we should have had an abortion
based on the 50-50 chance and the doctor
did bring that up as an option to which
Marie replied yes my son has a 50 chance
of having MTM but he has a 100 chance of
being loved
I thought that was a really cool thing
to say but according to Jordan's
perfectly functioning Mortal Compass
that was one of the most evil things
ever said by anyone so evil in fact that
my entire family line is a danger to
humanity except for my mother who is
suspiciously absent from Jordan's email
one of the underlying moral principles
for Jordan is that quality of life is
more important than life quality of life
trumps life if someone is going to have
a low quality of life he's better off
not living now you can make that case in
certain instances suppose someone is in
constant agonizing pain with no hope and
nothing to look forward to and wants to
die what do you do I get that
but what if you're pregnant and your son
has a 50 50 chance of having a disease
that will leave him with really really
weak muscles and the disease is somewhat
close to being cured
according to our new friend Jordan if
you don't abort that baby you're so
undeniably evil that the world would be
a better place without your entire
family line
what if you have the baby anyway and he
has MTM according to another new friend
if you take care of him after he's born
you're a normie who behaves like a
sociopath
what if you're a normie who behaves like
a sociopath so you take care of your son
for 15 years and then he dies well
whatever you do don't so much as mention
any of your religious beliefs because if
you do you might provoke the wrong
atheist who will be all too happy to
remind you that you shouldn't worship
God if he doesn't give your son properly
functioning muscles
see how I assembled a full range of
criticisms to absolutely bury myself in
a coffin made a pure fear under six feet
of airtight atheist reasoning
let's see if I can Houdini myself out of
this one okay now that we're clear on
what the criticisms are I'm going to
answer them
but David why are you going to answer
people who are saying all these mean
things
oh there's a reason there's a reason
but there's a pretty significant black
hole-ish space-time bending obstacle
here because I'll be responding to
people whose view of the world warps
reality as I know it they see the
universe very very differently from the
way I see it their view of good bad
right wrong moral obligation and so on
is radically opposed to my own even on
matters that involve the life and death
of a baby
they haven't offered any foundation or
justification for their claims so the
claims are just floating in the air like
bubbles waiting to be popped but if I
simply say the opposite of what they say
without any foundation or justification
then it's all just words words to be led
out to battle against other words as
Lewis once said so I'm inclined to give
some kind of framework to My Views to
show how it's all connected
our new friends may say but David why
should we listen to you you heartless
evil monster who takes care of special
needs kids and also posts tweets about
his beliefs
well you guys messaged me
you messaged me am I allowed to respond
or is anyone who answers you evil and
immoral
I carefully considered your claims
didn't I how about carefully considering
mine so that at the very least you'll
understand why we see things so
differently
fair is fair isn't it
now we could go into ethics and
metaethics but that might get boring and
Technical and I want to keep things as
simple as possible for our new Twitter
friends so I'm just going to share a
story
since we're partly analyzing
Christianity here I'll share a story
from the Bible and since we're talking
about the ethics of killing my son let's
go through the story of God commanding
Abraham to sacrifice Isaac atheists
already love going to this story they
say look at how Wicked God is ordering
Abraham to kill his own son which is
ironic considering the messages they
send me telling me I'm wicked for not
killing my own son
so let's go through the story of Abraham
and Isaac but let's do something that
our atheist friends Almost Never Do
let's try to understand it
here goes
in the ancient world your love for your
God was measured by the value of the
sacrifice you brought to the altar
the greater the value of your sacrifice
the greater your Devotion to your God
hence in the land of Canaan followers of
the god Malik believed that a man's
ultimate Act of piety was sacrificing
his own child to Malik the priests would
heat up a bronze statue of the Pagan God
until it was glowing The Devout would
Place their children into its fiery arms
and the children would burn
then came Abraham one of the most famous
stories in the Old Testament indeed one
of the most famous stories in the world
is the story of God commanding Abraham
to sacrifice his son Isaac Abraham was
so faithful to God that he was ready to
obey God's command to sacrifice what was
to Abraham the most precious thing in
the world his son Isaac he loved God so
much that he tied up his son put him on
a pile of wood and was about to plunge a
knife into him
critics of the Bible look at this and
say God told Abraham to sacrifice his
own son and Abraham was going to obey
him
how barbaric what an evil book the god
of the Bible is a monster and so was
Abraham for obeying him
but as usual the critics completely
missed the point and they're not simply
missing some insignificant random Point
here they're missing what may be the
most amazing life-changing mind-blowing
Point that's ever been made in the
history of forever
and I challenge every last one of you
Christian atheist Muslim Jew Hindu
whatever you may be I challenge you to
read through this with me until you get
the point and then find any Story by
anyone ever that's this deep this
profound this powerful this Epic
challenge accepted
good Genesis 22.
sometime later God tested Abraham he
said to him Abraham
here I am he replied then God said take
your son your only son whom you love
Isaac and go to the region of Moriah
sacrifice him there as a burnt offering
on a mountain I will show you
Abraham of course had another son
Ishmael but Ishmael had been cast out in
Genesis 21 leaving Abraham with Isaac as
his only son and as his heir
God tells Abraham to take Isaac to the
region of Moriah which is the region of
Jerusalem
early the next morning Abraham got up
and loaded his donkey he took with him
two of his servants and his son Isaac
when he had cut enough wood for the
burnt offering he set out for the place
God had told him about
on the third day Abraham looked up and
saw the place in the distance he said to
his servants stay here with the donkey
while I and the boy go over there we
will worship and then we will come back
to you
Abraham took the wood for the burnt
offering and placed it on his son Isaac
notice that Isaac had to carry the wood
on which he was to be sacrificed and he
himself carried the fire and the knife
as the two of them went on together
Isaac spoke up and said to his father
Abraham father
yes my son Abraham replied the fire and
wood are here Isaac said but where is
the Lamb for the burnt offering
Abraham obviously hadn't told anyone
what he was about to do
Abraham answered God himself will
provide the lamb for the burnt offering
my son and the two of them went on
together
interesting Abraham a prophet says that
God himself will provide a lamb for the
burnt offering
when they reached the place God had told
him about Abraham built an altar there
and arranged the wood on it he bound his
son Isaac and laid him on the altar on
top of the wood
then he reached out his hand and took
the knife to slay his son
but the angel of the Lord called out to
him from Heaven Abraham Abraham
here I am he replied do not lay a hand
on the boy he said do not do anything to
him now I know that you fear God because
you have not withheld from me your son
your only son
who told Abraham to stop the sacrifice
the angel of the Lord
there are lots of angels in the Bible
the word Angel simply means messenger
but this particular messenger called the
angel of the Lord here is no ordinary
angel
he's a messenger who speaks for God but
who is also identified as God
even here in Genesis 22 the angel of the
Lord speaks as God he says you have not
withheld from me your son
so according to the angel of the Lord
Abraham was offering a sacrifice to him
to the angel of the Lord
Abraham looked up and there in a Thicket
he saw a ram caught by its horns he went
over and took the RAM and sacrificed it
as a burnt offering instead of his son
so Abraham called that place the Lord
will provide and to this day it is said
on the mountain of the Lord it will be
provided
Abraham told Isaac that God himself
would provide a lamb for the sacrifice
but God provided a ram
where's the lamb what about the lamb
Abraham called that place the Lord will
provide where were they the region of
Mariah
Mount Moriah just so you know is the
Temple mount in Jerusalem as we read in
second chronicles 3 then Solomon began
to build the Temple of the Lord in
Jerusalem on Mount Moriah where the Lord
had appeared to his father David
so there's a specific Mountain Mount
Moriah and there's the region of Mariah
Abraham was somewhere in the area of
Jerusalem God showed him a specific
Place God provided his own sacrifice and
for many centuries Abraham's descendants
would say on the mountain of the Lord it
will be provided
the angel of the Lord called to Abraham
from Heaven a second time and said I
swear by myself declares the Lord that
because you have done this and have not
withheld your son your only son I will
surely bless you and make your
descendants as numerous as the stars in
the sky and as the sand on the seashore
your descendants will take possession of
the cities of their enemies and through
your Offspring All Nations on Earth will
be blessed because you have obeyed me
the angel of the Lord declares I swear
by myself I will surely bless you I will
make your descendants as numerous as the
stars in the sky and as the sand on the
seashore your descendants will take
possession of the cities of their
enemies and through your Offspring All
Nations on Earth will be blessed because
you have obeyed me
that is quite the promise
thousands of years before any of us had
ever heard about any of this the angel
of the Lord told some completely unknown
guy who lived in the middle of nowhere
that all nations on Earth would be
blessed through his offspring
but Abraham was ready to sacrifice his
offspring his son Isaac when God told
him to
keep in mind Isaac was no ordinary son
he was the son of Promise years earlier
Abraham had complained that even though
God had blessed him abundantly God
hadn't blessed him with a son to be his
heir and Abraham knew there was already
too late because he and his wife were
way way way way past their Prime to put
it mildly
but God told him in Genesis 15 that he
would indeed have a son and that his
descendants would be like the stars in
the sky
by the way this passage is where we see
what made Abraham unique among his
contemporaries Abraham wasn't unique
because he was willing to sacrifice his
son there were pagans who were willing
to do that
Abraham was unique because God kept
making promises to him that sounded
increasingly unbelievable but Abraham
kept believing that God was going to do
what he promised Abraham believed the
Lord and He credited to him as
righteousness
in Genesis 17 God told him that the son
of Promise would be born to Sarah who
would be the mother of Nations God would
establish an Everlasting Covenant
through Isaac
so when God commanded Abraham to
sacrifice his son this was a very
special son this son was prophesied this
son would have a miraculous birth the
Everlasting Covenant would come through
this son
and then God said
remember all that stuff I said about
your son
remember all the promises I made about
him
you know how all of your hopes and
dreams are riding on this one particular
son
now I want you to sacrifice him as a
burnt offering
Abraham's God suddenly started sounding
just like the gods of the pagans
sacrifice your child to me
we look at this as people in the 21st
century we look at this as people who
came long after the complete reversal of
paganism that was about to take place
but try to think about this from the
perspective of the people around Abraham
Abraham was surrounded by people who
were convinced that the greatest thing
they could ever do was sacrifice their
children to their God
Abraham was ready to do it but the angel
of the Lord told him to stop
the takeaway message of the story of
Abraham and Isaac for the surrounding
culture was this
Abraham is just as devout as the most
devout of any of you he's the sort of
person who's willing to do whatever his
God commands he loves his God so much
that he's ready to sacrifice what he
values most in this world
the difference between you and Abraham
is not that Abraham is willing to
sacrifice his son some of you are
willing to do that too
the difference between you and Abraham
is that Abraham's God doesn't want him
to sacrifice his son
Abraham's God stops him from sacrificing
his son
Abraham's God provides his own sacrifice
so putting all of this together God
who's no ordinary God orders his Prophet
whose No Ordinary Prophet to sacrifice
his son who is no ordinary son but the
sacrifice is stopped by an Angel whose
No Ordinary angel
end of story right wrong the story has a
beginning a middle and an end and this
story isn't finished because there was
something about a lamb and an
Everlasting Covenant and All Nations
being blessed through Abraham's
offspring
you didn't forget about that did you
not going too fast for you am I atheists
so how was God going to bless all
nations through Abraham's offspring well
we start getting some hints through the
prophets in Isaiah 53 we find a prophecy
about someone who would be punished for
the sins of others
surely he took up our pain and bore our
suffering yet we considered him punished
by God stricken by him and Afflicted but
he was pierced for our transgressions he
was crushed for our iniquities the
punishment that brought us peace was on
him and by his wounds we are healed we
all like sheep have gone astray each of
us has turned to our own way and the
lord has laid on him the iniquity of us
all
the passage even says that he would be
led like a lamb to the slaughter
but then we get some puzzling details
for instance in Zechariah 12 God says
they will look on me the one they have
pierced and they will mourn for him as
One Mourns for an only child and grieve
bitterly for him as one Grieves for a
firstborn son
this is God speaking and God says that
people will look at him after piercing
him
how does someone Pierce God and look at
and then oddly enough after God says
they will look on me he switches to the
third person and refers to the one who's
pierced as him as if there's some sort
of distinction between God and the one
who's pierced
I'm getting confused
we read about the angel of the Lord who
somehow the Lord even though he's
distinct from the Lord there's the one
who was pierced to somehow God and
distinct from God
is there anyone who can clear this up
for us
let's check the Gospel of John starting
at the very first verse
in the beginning was the word and the
Word was with God and the Word was God
so the Word was God but was also with
God that reminds me of the Angel of the
Lord the messenger who spoke for God but
was also God and in case you're
wondering yes the angel of the Lord was
the pre-incarnate Jesus he was the
Eternal Word who was with God and who
was God but he entered creation as Jesus
of Nazareth via the Incarnation because
how else would they pierce God
verse 14. and the word who was God
became flesh and dwelt among us and we
have seen his glory glory as of the only
son from the father full of grace and
truth
so here the distinction between the Lord
and the angel of the Lord the
distinction between God and the word of
God is the distinction between the
father and the son
John the Baptist started preaching
before Jesus but when John saw Jesus
approaching he said in verse 29 Behold
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world
is this the lamb we've been waiting for
John also said in the same passage I saw
the Spirit descend from heaven like a
dove and it remained on him remained on
Jesus I myself did not know him but he
who sent me to baptize with water said
to me he on whom you see the spirit
descend and remain this is he who
baptizes with the Holy Spirit and I have
seen and have borne witness that this is
the son of God
John is referring to Jesus baptism which
we read about in Matthew 3. and when
Jesus was baptized immediately he went
up from the water and behold the heavens
were opened for him and he saw the
spirit of God descending like a dove and
coming to rest on him and behold a voice
from Heaven said this is my beloved Son
with whom I am well pleased
the voice is the voice of God the Father
notice that God the father and God the
Holy Spirit together identify Jesus as
the Divine son which is how John knew
who Jesus really was
John the Baptist identified Jesus as the
Lamb of God who would take away the sin
of the world
John identified Jesus as the Son of God
because that's what God the father and
God the Holy Spirit revealed to him
you're not going to reject the witness
of John the Baptist are you Muslims
a little later in the Gospel of John in
chapter 3 Jesus is having a discussion
with a Pharisee named Nicodemus
since Nicodemus had a thorough knowledge
of the scriptures Jesus asks him
how do you not understand what's going
on here
and then we get the most famous verse of
any book in history John 3 16 for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
son that whoever believes in him should
not perish but have eternal life
this verse is famous in its own right
but I don't think you get the full
impact unless you read it in light of
the greater Biblical context
again among the pagans your love for
your God was measured by the value of
your sacrifice the most precious thing
you could ever have would be your
children especially if you only had one
child and especially if that child was
your heir
so the greatest thing you could do was
sacrifice your only son to your God
that's how you would demonstrate your
love for your God
ordered Abraham to sacrifice his son a
very special son a son like no other the
son of promise
then the angel of the Lord aka the word
AKA The Eternal Divine son aka the
pre-incarnate Christ stopped Abraham
because God provides his own sacrifice
God would provide a lamb
then God provided a ram
what about the lamb well the lamb turns
out to be the angel of the Lord the word
the Divine son the pre-incarnate Christ
so when Abraham said that God would
provide a lamb the lamb that God would
provide was there
but lamb aka the angel of the Lord aka
the word aka the sun aka the
pre-incarnate Christ was the one who
told Abraham to shut down the sacrifice
of Isaac
the son the word the angel of the Lord
enters creation as Jesus of Nazareth and
this is definitely no ordinary son this
is the Eternal Divine son who because of
his Incarnation is also the son of
Abraham the son of Isaac the son of
Jacob the son of David he's the Messiah
he's the one through whom all nations of
the world would be blessed he's the one
through whom the world would be saved
Jesus is the ultimate son of promise
everything all the promises the entire
world is riding on this son of promise
this is the most important son ever
and we mocked him spit on him hit him
lashed him to a gory mess and nailed him
to a cross
ironically some of the descendants of
Abraham United with the pagans to have
him crucified let that sink in
Abraham was willing to kill Isaac just
like the most devout pagans were willing
to kill their sons Abraham sacrificed
the ram that the angel of the Lord
provided as a substitute for Isaac then
when the ultimate Son Of Promise
appeared descendants of Abraham and
descendants of pagans worked together to
execute him where in the region of
Moriah
like Isaac before him Jesus didn't fight
back
in John 19 we have the complaints of the
Jewish leaders
we have a law and according to that law
he ought to die because he has made
himself the son of God
the Romans didn't care much about this
but they did have a problem with someone
claiming to be king claiming to be king
would put you at odds with Caesar
so they took Jesus and he went out
bearing his own cross remember Isaac
carrying the wood for the fire to the
place called the place of a skull which
in Aramaic is called Golgotha
There They Crucified him and with him
two others one on either side and Jesus
between them pilate also wrote an
inscription and put it on the cross it
read Jesus of Nazareth the king of the
Jews
calling a crucified man the king of the
Jews was simultaneously an insult to the
Jewish leaders hey I know you hate this
guy so I'm calling him your king and a
standard Roman warning to anyone
thinking about challenging Caesar
the irony is that it was true Jesus is
the king of the Jews and the king of
everyone else
but we nailed him to a cross and he died
and then we read for these things took
place that the scripture might be
fulfilled not one of his bones will be
broken and again another scripture says
they will look on him whom they have
pierced remember Zechariah 12 where God
says they will look on me the one they
have pierced
Jesus followers picked up on that too in
fact they picked up on a lot of things
in Acts 3 Peter heals a lame beggar in
the name of Jesus and that gives him the
opportunity to share some of his
Newfound knowledge
while the man held on to Peter and John
all the people were astonished and came
running to them in the place called
Solomon's Colonnade when Peter saw this
he said to them
fellow Israelites why does this surprise
you why do you stare at us as if by our
own power or godliness we had made this
man walk the god of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob the god of our fathers has
glorified his servant Jesus you handed
him over to be killed and you disowned
him before Pilate though he had decided
to let him go you disowned the holy and
righteous one and asked that a murderer
be released to you
you killed the author of life but God
raised him from the dead we Are
Witnesses of this by faith in the name
of Jesus this man whom you see and know
was made strong it is Jesus name and the
faith that comes through him that has
completely healed him as you can all see
Peter calls Jesus the author of Life
which would be God but God raised him
from the dead there's that recurring
distinction between God and a servant
who's also God
now fellow Israelites I know that you
acted in ignorance as did your leaders
but this is how God fulfilled what he
had foretold through all the prophets
saying that his Messiah would suffer
God did what he said he was going to do
and he did it through you repent then
and turn to God so that your sins may be
wiped out that times of refreshing may
come from the Lord and that he may send
the Messiah who has been appointed for
you even Jesus Heaven Must receive him
until the time comes for God to restore
everything as he promised long ago
through his holy prophets for Moses said
the Lord your God will raise up for you
a prophet like me from among your own
people you must listen to everything he
tells you anyone who does not listen to
him will be completely cut off from
their people
funny my Muslim friends insist that the
verses Peter quotes here are about
Muhammad
indeed beginning with Samuel all the
prophets who have spoken have foretold
these days and you are Heirs of the
prophets and of the Covenant God made
with your fathers he said to Abraham
through your Offspring All Peoples on
Earth will be blessed when God raised up
his servant he sent him first to you to
bless you by turning each of you from
your Wicked Ways
Peter brings it back to the story of
Abraham and Isaac when the angel of the
Lord promised Abraham that all nations
would be blessed through his offspring
Peter points out that God sent his
servant Jesus aka the Lamb of God who
takes away the sins of the world aka the
angel of the Lord aka the word of God
AKA The Son of God to the Jews first
later in Acts we see how the gospel
spread to the Gentiles as well so that
all nations would be blessed through
Jesus
but there's also this part about God
raising Jesus from the dead
interestingly that was part of the story
about Abraham and Isaac too we read in
Hebrews 11 by faith Abraham when he was
tested offered up Isaac and he who had
received the promises was in the act of
offering up his only son of whom it was
said through Isaac shall your Offspring
be named he considered that God was able
even to raise him from the dead from
which figuratively speaking he did
receive him back
when we went through Genesis 22 we saw
that as Abraham was about to go
sacrifice Isaac he said to his servants
stay here with the donkey while I and
the boy go over there we will worship
and then we will come back to you we
both of us will come back to you
why did Abraham say that Isaac would
return When Isaac was about to be
sacrificed
well according to Hebrews Abraham
reasoned that God could raise Isaac from
the dead
in other words Abraham had two pieces of
information to go on one God said that
Abraham's descendants would be like the
stars and that the Covenant would be
through Isaac
two God ordered Abraham to sacrifice
Isaac
Abraham believed God and did the math if
Isaac's about to die and I'm going to
have a ton of descendants through Isaac
then God is going to raise him from the
dead
think about how this sets the stage for
the Messiah
there are prophecies about the Messiah
being the blessing to All Nations and
ruling the world
there are also prophecies about the
Messiah claiming that he would suffer
and die
how do we make sense of this well we
could say it makes no sense for the
Messiah to die and rule the world so
these prophecies must be talking about
different people that's one way to make
sense of the conflicting messages from
the prophets
but if you think like Abraham how would
you reconcile the conflicting messages
you'd say if God tells us that the
Messiah is going to suffer and die and
that all nations are going to be blessed
through the Messiah and his Reign then
God is going to raise the Messiah from
the dead
that's what you would expect if you were
going to apply abrahamic thinking to
Messianic prophecies and it's exactly
what happened
now as this story unfolded did you catch
the complete total reversal of ancient
paganism
the ancient pagans said sacrifice your
son to show your love for your God
the god of the Bible says not how this
works shut it down you don't offer your
son to show your love for me I offer my
son to show my love for you
it's no longer for Abraham's so loved
God that he gave his only son it's for
God so loved the world that he gave his
only son
God Judo flips the Pagan script he turns
the entire system upside down no more
sacrificing your way to God God
sacrifices his way to you and he brings
his own sacrifice
you can see this all the way from the
first book of the Bible to the last book
of the Bible from Genesis to Revelation
because it was the plan all along
Revelation 13 8.
all inhabitants of the earth will
worship the Beast all whose names have
not been written in the Lamb's Book of
Life a lamb who was slain from the
creation of the world
the lamb was slain from the creation of
the world but notice what else this
prophecy says
everyone whose name hasn't been written
in the Lamb's Book of Life Will Worship
the Beast
if you reject the reversal of paganism
through the gospel you go right back to
paganism
here you may be thinking nonsense David
Society has evolved Beyond paganism we
don't need this God and this lamb and
this gospel to tell us not to sacrifice
our children
oh I think someone does
have you heard of The Grooming gangs in
the UK thousands and thousands of little
girls were groomed raped and pimped for
decades
police social workers prosecutors they
knew exactly what was happening and they
let it happen because they didn't want
to be called islamophobes for exposing
the Pakistani Muslims who were devouring
these young girls
what were the enlightened new pagans of
Great Britain doing
they were sacrificing their daughters to
their new God
what about the U.S
when parents decide that it's a good
idea to have their confused children
dismembered put on an operating table as
part of an ongoing mengele-like medical
experiment
are the parents really doing what's best
for their kids or are they showing their
Devotion to their new God
what about The Unborn
if you go back just 20 or 30 years the
pro-choice crowd said they wanted
abortion to be safe legal and rare they
wanted it to be rare it wasn't something
to be happy about
now people have abortion parties
there are abortion celebrations women
where I had an abortion t-shirts
it's one thing to have an abortion it's
something else entirely to celebrate and
brag about it
why would a woman celebrate killing her
offspring
because it demonstrates her Devotion to
her new God
have human beings really moved past
their Pagan inclinations or as we turn
away from the lamb God provided are we
entering a new golden age of pagan
worship
you can let me know your answer right
after drag queen Story Hour
fasten your seatbelts kids because
reality is a hard wall to crash into
so that's the story of Abraham and Isaac
what's it got to do with me and my son
Reed
well when you read a story like the
story of Abraham and Isaac
and you really try to understand it and
you see that it's part of a bigger story
and you see how this bigger story
unfolds over thousands of years and you
see how everything is connected to
everything else you start to see that
we're part of the story as well
this isn't a random story sitting on a
bookshelf that you pick up and read and
then put back on the Shelf we're in this
one you me the strong the weak the
healthy the sick the lovers the haters
even our Muslim friends who say no the
story of Abraham and Isaac is actually
about abrahamic Ishmael which completely
destroys the meaning because that's just
what heresies do
whoever you are you're in this story
with me and not only are we part of the
same story we're writing the story you
get to help write your own part in the
story we're writing our parts right now
you can be the hero you can be the
villain you can be the champion of good
ideas you can be the champion of bad
ideas you can be the friend of the
fatherless the defender of the
downtrodden the enemy of oppressors
or you can be the emotional equivalent
of a toddler throwing a tantrum on the
floor of the checkout aisle at Walmart
because Mommy wouldn't buy him a pack of
Starbursts
we're in this story together and we're
writing it together
if you understand the plot you start to
see events good and bad from an eternal
perspective where the value of people or
things isn't limited to how much
pleasure or Comfort they bring you at
some given moment
modern atheism is a bunch of people
trying to take themselves out of the
story that we're all in it's like
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern trying to
take themselves out of Hamlet
but when you try to take yourself out of
this story and you lose the main plot
all you're left with is whatever's in
front of you and how it makes you feel
imagine someone picking up a thousand
page novel that you've never read going
to page 487
cutting out two sentences from that page
and just giving you those two sentences
to go on
he gives you two sentences from page 487
of this thousand page novel and then he
tells you to figure out what's going on
will you have any clue what's going on
in that book
no you'll take those two sentences and
fill in the rest of the plot with your
own feelings and Fantasies particularly
the feelings and Fantasies that are
fashionable in whatever group you happen
to be in
and any plot that you somehow manage to
weld together will bear almost no
resemblance to the plot of the actual
novel
what I find utterly amazing about our
new atheist friends and I'm talking
about the perpetually angry and hostile
ones here is that once they put all
their feelings and Fantasies and
Fashions and fads together into some
confused disjointed silly boring
Frankenstein monster of an ideology
they'll jump on Twitter and throw that
mess in my face like I'm supposed to
live according to their incoherent
nonsense
here David try a slice of our uncooked
peanut butter pineapple and pickle pizza
served in a Dirty Ashtray with a side
order of rat droppings and a tall glass
of fermented depression
how about no
the moral obligations they try to impose
make no sense according to their own
world view so why do they try to impose
them on others
I'll tell you why
Augustine said to God you have made us
for yourself O Lord and our hearts are
restless until they rest in you
our atheist friends have Restless Hearts
they always find something to cling to
like a security blanket
they don't cling to something that's
evil they cling to something that's good
or true but which has been removed from
its proper place and disconnected from
more important things
Chesterton said
a fad or heresy is the exaltation of
something which even if true is
secondary or temporary in its nature
against those things which are essential
and eternal those things which always
prove themselves true in the long run
so for example sex is good
until you build your entire life around
it and you disconnect it from things
like love and faithfulness and you strip
away its meaning
tolerance is good until you exalt it
above wisdom and Justice and truth and
Common Sense and you start despising
people who don't disconnect it from
other things that are good
avoiding needless pain is good until you
start telling people to kill babies who
have weak muscles
atheists are constantly latching on to
something even to something good like a
particular virtue but it's always
something that's secondary or temporary
as opposed to things that are essential
and eternal
so we try to tell them that even though
what they're latching on to may be good
it'll never be enough
but they don't get it
it's like trying to explain to a baby
that he's not going to fill his belly by
sucking his thumb
the baby won't understand your
explanation because he's a baby
so you just have to shove a boob in his
mouth and hope for the best or he'll
starve
the problem is that you can take one of
these new atheists and send him up a
mountain of boobs and he'll come back
down still sucking his thumb
and what's the atheist response to
everything I've said in this video
but David you haven't proved to me that
what you're saying is true as if they
prove anything they ever say
it's wrong to mention your religious
beliefs when your son dies
really
can you prove that
don't ever forget they're only Skeptics
when we say something when they say
something they're the infallible cherubs
of Dogma
this clown skepticism of the new
atheists isn't a tool for avoiding
falsehood it's a tool for avoiding
realities they don't like
Richard Dawkins was asked if God did
exist what sort of evidence could God
give you that would convince you that he
exists
Dawkins couldn't think of anything he
said that if God audibly spoke to him he
would dismiss it and conclude that he's
hallucinating
he said that even if God wrote a message
to him in the Stars he still wouldn't
believe in God because the message in
the Stars could have been put there by
powerful aliens trying to trick him
Peter Atkins agreed that if God wrote a
message in the Stars he wouldn't
consider it evidence for God he went on
to say that even if he died and woke up
and was confronted by Saint Peter at the
Pearly Gates he still wouldn't believe
Mike Lacona asked Matt Dillahunty about
what would qualify as evidence for the
supernatural Mike said look
if I was beheaded in front of everyone
and you saw my decapitated corpse and
then I came back and I walked in and I
told you about my trip to heaven and I
told you about someone I met there
someone who had had a private
conversation with you and I knew the
details of that conversation even though
the person was dead would that convince
you that something Supernatural had
occurred
Dillahunty immediately replied no
atheists set up a methodology that is
impervious to evidence
and then they demand evidence
it's like a flat earther saying just so
you know I will automatically reject any
evidence that the Earth is round now
prove to me that the Earth is round
for those of you who haven't gone the
skeptic clown route
think about the story we went through
and how deep it goes
and how it connects everything to
everything else
sometimes the proof
is in the profundity
now back to the criticisms I said I
would respond to should we have aborted
Paley because he had a 50 50 chance of
having MTM
should we have let Reid and Paley die
once it was clear that they had a muscle
disease
if you're only guiding moral principle
here is well if life is going to be
tough for someone he's better off dead
you might think that offing babies is
the path to Paradise
but that's not my guiding moral
principle and the ethical implications
of that moral principle and the
questions that arise about who would get
to decide who lives and who dies are
pretty disturbing
but what if we ignore ungrounded ethical
theories and we just focus on the lives
of the children and their impact on the
world
Reed had an extremely tough life
but apart from times when he was
actually in pain for some reason he was
almost always happy and smiling and
dancing
he didn't complain
he would occasionally get annoyed but he
definitely didn't share the pessimistic
attitude toward life that consumes these
enraged Twitter critics
in fact in spite of his disability
Reed was happier than his haters seemed
to be
why is MTM on the verge of being cured
not too long ago no one was researching
MTM because kids who were born with it
and there weren't many of them all died
there wasn't much of a reason to try
curing a disease when no one had the
disease because everyone who got it was
already dead
but then due to Medical advances the
babies started surviving and parents
started fighting for their kids and
convincing medical researchers to start
working on MTM
this disease is going to be cured
because there are kids like Reed and
Paley whose parents are fighting for
them
if parents didn't fight for them parents
just let them die the disease would
never be cured
so either this generation of kids with
MTM will be cured or the next generation
of kids with MTM will be cured either
way it's specifically because parents
didn't just let their kids die that
future Generations won't have to die
some kids have tough lives now so that
kids in the future won't have to
what about the impact these special
needs kids have on the people around
them
when Reed was still really young he
started randomly pulling out his trach
tube now that's what he breathes through
he would look around and all of a sudden
yank it out and toss it like he just
didn't want it and we'd rush to put it
back in
I thought he was trying to get attention
but one day one of my older Sons was
still pretty young too said maybe Reed
is realizing that he's different
maybe he's pulling out his trach because
he wants to be like the rest of us maybe
we should wear trakes when we're around
Reed so that he won't feel like he's
different
he meant that we should cut the ends off
some trach tubes so we didn't have to
actually insert them and then wear trait
collars when we were around read so that
Reed would think it's normal
what was going on there
that was the son of a psychopath
figuring out ways to help his little
brother and teaching his father about
showing creative compassion
back in 2013 the Make-A-Wish Foundation
sent our family on a trip to Disney
World we spent a week there
taking two kids with MTM on a week-long
trip is a lot of work they have a ton of
equipment and when you're out all day
with them you have to bring everything
they need for the entire day plus
emergency supplies in case something
goes wrong it's a lot of stuff so we had
to tell our older kids listen guys this
trip is mainly for Reed and Paley
they don't get to do a lot of really fun
things so this is mostly for them and
you too are going to have to spend most
of your time at Disney World helping us
take care of your brothers
our older kids were still pretty young
so I was wondering if they were going to
be resentful
they were in the most fun place in the
world for a kid and they had to spend
most of their time there pushing their
brothers around in wheelchairs or
carrying supplies
now there were times when we said okay
we'll stay here with Reed and Paley
while you guys go on some rides but most
of the time they were helping take care
of their brothers
and they never showed the slightest hint
that they were at all bothered by the
fact that other kids were running around
playing while they were helping their
brothers
they were happy making sure their little
brothers were having fun
you see this sort of thing happen over
and over again and you realize that
these special needs kids spend their
entire lives making everyone around them
stronger more compassionate less selfish
they constantly make everyone around
them better people
it doesn't have to be that way
you could treat them terribly and become
a worse person for you
but when you try to give them the best
lives they can have they force you to
grow as a human being
I would argue that if you've spent your
entire life making everyone around you
better
you've lived a good life
my son Reed was always a blessing to
everyone
and now even in death
seems like he just blessed you with
let's face it one of the greatest
Christian videos ever made
I challenge you keyboard jihadis and
atheists again I'm talking about the
perpetually enraged atheist I challenge
you to have a better impact on the
people around you and on the world than
my son Reed had
but you won't be able to do it if all
you do is sit around all day whining and
insulting people on social media
what about the claim that we shouldn't
bring up our religious beliefs when a
son dies a lot of atheists gave a thumbs
up when someone scolded me for saying
Reed went to be with Jesus they do not
want to hear anything about Jesus when
someone's son dies
how did that work out for you atheists
you should put me in a mall because I'm
an escalator
my son died and I turned the sad event
into an epic message of Hope and
transformation I wonder where I got that
idea oh it's exactly what God did
would our atheist friends prefer
hopelessness and despair
not on my watch
my son's death led to insults and
mockery from keyboard jihadis I took the
insults and mockery and transformed them
into a glorious victory
I wonder where I got that idea oh it's
exactly what God did
see why it helps to know the plot
that leaves us with the claim that I
shouldn't worship God if he doesn't give
my son a properly functioning body
I did my doctoral dissertation on what's
regarded as the most sophisticated
version of the argument from Evil it's
the Bayesian argument from Evil so I
have quite a few thoughts about the
argument from Evil I can share those
some other time if you're interested
but since this was raised specifically
as a criticism against me I'll just say
here that I understand when people who
are going through terrible situations in
life cry out come on God why is this
happening
some of the greatest heroes in the Bible
complained a lot when things went
horribly wrong I get that
but at the end of the day
it's never crossed my mind to be
anything but thankful for all my sons
why would I hate and despise God when
I'm filled with gratitude
because some atheists on Twitter don't
like it when I'm grateful
God gave his own son a properly
functioning Body And that son offered up
his body for my son
I can't bring myself to complain
Reed spent the first six months of his
life in a children's hospital
all he ever saw for his first six months
of his life
where the walls and ceiling and
Equipment inside the hospital and the
people who are there
he had no concept of life outside the
room he was in
I was in California when Marie sent me a
picture
the nurses had helped her put Reed and
his equipment in a stroller so he could
finally go outside
Marie rolled him out the door
and Reed looked up
and saw the sky for the first time
this little boy
who had only known the inside of a
hospital this little boy who had been
poked and prodded and cut by doctors and
nurses
was in total awe as he discovered that
reality was much bigger far more amazing
than everything he had experienced in
his room at the Children's Hospital
if this was his expression when he saw
the sky
what do you think he looked like when he
finally saw the face of the Almighty who
made the sky
what are you going to look like when you
see him
[Music]